can you say good morning John good
morning John I'm a big fan of Charlie
McDonnell and his YouTube show Charlie
is so cool like and now he's sleeping in
my house while July was here I wanted to
ask Charlie some questions but I've
always wanted to ask Charlie I haven't
really I just wrote these last night how
are you doing it feels weird that I'm
not making a video today I know right so
I feel most at home now being here in
front of the camera and thinking at
least I'm in a video of some sort I
remember after brother 2.0 ended I was
just like what do you do with time
how's Missoula lovely it's nice and
little yeah I like that Bath is quite
compact and I like the fact that you can
just sort of you can just walk anywhere
and birth them just be at the right
place I mean this is slightly bigger
because it's America so it's driving
places we ride our bikes around the
heart
uh-huh but we don't have one for you I
would have been fun we could have gone
for a bike ride I should rent a tandem
that could be a whole video yes we could
be doing this interview on a bike it's
turn off now let's text so that what was
the last thing you screamed at I don't
think I really screamed at much you know
what it would be like to scream yeah I
could scream if you want me to are you
sure
I went bungee jumping that's like one of
the scenarios possible singing no III
know I bleed silence all the way down
actually I did scream but I only
screamed because I felt like I needed to
going down and I was just like and that
was it and then I just sort of went oh
ah that's the last thing I screamed okay
I need a bungee jumping if you could
eliminate a word from the English
language
what would you eliminate no one could
ever say it again moist moist dude you
know that that's my favorite word if you
could kill baby Hitler would you kill
baby Hitler I don't know why after like
years of evil baby orphanage you are
asking me this question I'm just saying
the orphanage is not an option you have
to kill a baby kill one person or let
all these other people die
yeah I'm gonna kill a baby what was your
worst challenge for challenge charlie
one more I tried to do like five
different challenges in one go and I
just threw up halfway through that and
the video never got made so probably
that one because it wasn't even a case
of like you don't even get anything done
exactly what will you tattoo on you
Pinkie Pie on your bicep dftba on the
inside of your lip
don't want any tattoos but no one are
gonna see this on the inside of your lip
but it will hurt very bad just like I
spend an hour going through extreme pain
and then we'll ever see what you've done
but you'll know forever that your lip
wants you to never forget to be awesome
okay do you find you you're
exceptionally gassy as a person you are
seeing with this cuz this is how you've
noticed no no you haven't seemed
exceptionally gassy at my house I do
fart whatever Annabelle you can leave a
fart at one place in London and go to a
different place that's probably not good
for other people no I mean just like up
on the escalator and I thought down here
and then they get to it and then
suddenly do you spend more time writing
a video or editing the video for the
past week I didn't really write anything
at all so I have been editing much more
but unless the video is like
significantly like effect heavy like
with Forever Yours I probably spend
about as much time writing it as I did
editing it mmm then it's more time
writing yeah do you spend more time like
making the video as a whole or playing
video games I spend more time making
videos but only just
since you like playing video games so
much do you want to go play video games
right now yeah okay definitely
all right into the video then show John
we will both see you on Tuesday we will
on the internet adios